[Music]
welcome to the reason Roundtable your
weekly libertarian podcast from the
magazine that is not on your ballot this
Tuesday so you can't play Masai and Matt
Wells joined by Nick Gillespie making
weird guttural noises Peter Superman and
Catherine mangyu giggling Ward how do
you do fellow citizens
howdy
Matt that was the worst in trouble
mid-term Madness Monday
a little alliteration to start out our
week let's get straight to it uh the uh
fate of democracy is in your hands
President Joseph Robinette Biden Jr said
yesterday uh warned MSNBC historian
Michael beschlas what's at stake is
whether we will be a democracy in the
future whether our children will be
arrested and conceivably killed
uh counters uh Karl Rove the Republican
strategist formerly known as Bush's
brain the Geniuses In The West Wing
thought they could make the election
about anything they wanted it to be
about a midterm election in particular
is about what the people want it to be
about Deep Thoughts From Karl Rove so
and Republicans reading the election is
about crime it's about inflation it's
about the economy it's about covid it's
about immigration immigration thank you
it's Jesus Christ he's interrupting the
word on my page
I thought this was participatory no it's
not Mastermind no okay get to the
question put the electrodes back on the
testicles uh whatever it is they were
never it's they were never close
this selection control of the United
States Senate hangs the balance there's
a pretty normal pendulum swing looking
uh like it's about to happen in the
house remember that on average something
like 26 uh uh president's party loses
about 26 seats in the first midterm but
also the chances of a uh pre-election
polling error is particularly High
because the kids don't answer their
phones and I can't really blame them uh
Libertarians as usual are Outsiders much
more so now than ever before and perhaps
we can add a useful uh outside
perspective that the currently hyper
panicked insiders are unable to achieve
so Catherine as a non-voting Anarchist
one-legged robot can you lead us in a
round of everyone giving their sense of
what is the single biggest important
thing from your perspective at stake in
this election to end all elections yeah
I heard this was the most most important
election of our lifetimes Matt so you
know right so why because they all are
every single one is every single one of
my lifetime has been the most important
election in my lifetime uh this one you
know obviously the rhetoric around it is
you know where democracy is at stake but
it's not clear in that kind of
um hysteria whether the outcome of the
election is determining whether we get
to keep having democracy or whether the
conduct during you know election day and
vote counting is the thing that we have
to keep an eye on probably both I guess
everything because everyone's just
losing their minds I have historically
been a skeptic of the uh often espoused
libertarian position that divided
government is good government I think
that
um you know there maybe I'm an idiot but
I just keep holding out hope that some
kind of minimally competent and
minimally you know libertarian friendly
government would still be better than
just a gridlocked nightmare Escape I Am
I'm coming over though to the side of
the team divided government and so I
think you know that's that's what's at
stake here if we end up with
um kind of meaningfully you know a
government meaningfully at odds with
itself in terms of the partisan balance
that we will at the very least not have
to see a replay of the of the these sort
of inter inter-democratic nightmare
where like Joe manchin you know ran the
country for a year and instead we will
see kind of a more classic tension
between the parties resulting in very
little getting done
um at this point I really can't see
anything that anyone in government is
proposing to do that I want to see done
um and so uh we might as well just have
gridlock wait you're not excited about
the debt limit Showdown over Medicare
and Social Security that's definitely
going to happen don't you start with me
I think
I think that limit Showdown though
that's like Spider-Man 3 or something
yeah somebody play the Bonanza Theme
Peter what's your uh uh single biggest
issue of importance that's at stake in
this location accordingly I think this
ish this election is mostly about
inflation not entirely but mostly in
some ways because inflation supersedes
and also encapsulates all other issues
right like there's a if you look at the
surveys and also just the reports
anecdata from voters they'll be like
well you know democracy abortion sure
all that stuff it's like seems important
but what actually matters is when I go
to the grocery store things are much
more expensive and the partisan polling
is I think pretty revealing here
Republicans have been worried about
inflation for a while they're they're
quite worried about it for obvious
reasons in part because it hurts their
pocketbooks in part because it's like a
it's a way of scoring points against
Democrats against Joe Biden right um but
Democrats and upper middle class voters
in recent months have actually grown
more concerned about inflation rather
than less and so even Democrats are
trending in a direction that is bad for
Joe Biden and his party
um and independent voters uh who are
obviously very important to elections
into the outcomes of Elections
independent voters are actually more
likely than Democrats or Republicans to
say inflation is creating serious stress
in their lives according to a new Wall
Street Journal poll so that's what
people are worried about then that tells
you about what the what this election I
think is really going to be about and
what's
it's amazing to me is the way that Biden
and his party have responded by trying
to treat this as a messaging problem
which is in some ways this is what
Democrats and to a lesser extent or in a
different way maybe Republicans always
try to do with problems they can't
really solve but the macro economy does
not respond
to speeches like you can't really you
can't you can't fix it with soaring
rhetoric it just doesn't care how many
times Joe Biden says come on man or you
know insists
right inflations it's like the
Terminator it's out there you know it
can't be bargained with it can't be
reasoned with it doesn't feel pity or
remorse it will absolutely not stop ever
until prices stop Rising I think is how
that goes I just think Democrats have
have not even bothered to reckon with
this in a really serious way
um in part because to do so would be to
acknowledge that Joe Biden's big
signature policy when he came into
office uh was to pass a giant spending
bill that even people on his own party
said was too big and was likely to
trigger runaway inflation Democrats went
ahead and did it they did it on a
partisan basis and now we are where we
are
uh you know uh Peter uh Joy Reid Joanne
Reed from MSNBC taught me that um no one
had used used the word inflation until
Republicans in the scare mongering media
started using it so I think you're part
of the problem uh Nick what is your
sense of what is at stake for nicholaspi
I was going to also add to Peter though
that uh that you know the Stacey Abrams
at one point tried to wrap abortion into
inflation and it was something like you
know because now we can't get abortions
inflation is really out of control or
something and um so you know you got to
give people the price of a terminated
pregnancy is included in any measure of
CPI now but think of the spending that
you commit to if you let that kid come
you know to turn that's like you know a
couple hundred thousand dollars you are
just you're pouring gas on the economy
of the future Matt I uh to pick up on uh
actually what both Catherine and Peter
were saying I think the you know it's
it's the economy in the broadest terms
possible and it's not simply inflation
um I think it you know there is a
restructuring going on
um that has been going on for the past
20 years you've talked about it uh
recently on this podcast about you know
the labor force participation rate
younger people older people like who
who's in the economy who isn't
um on you know and then you see things
like inflation and you see things like
free trade and supply chain you know
problems where most people don't really
fully understand why this is I don't
know that anybody really fully
understands why any of this is happening
but there is a growing sense that things
are just not being taken care of or
acknowledged or nobody knows what's
going on and then you look to the people
who head up you know the two big parties
and it's Joe Biden on one hand who is a
bumbling fool and I was talking with a
bunch of democrat operatives you know
I'm not talking about just regular
voters or anything and they like they do
not have a sense of how badly Joe Biden
comes off to everyone in America except
that I mean he is [ __ ] out of it and
people everybody knows that and then
there's Donald Trump and you know I'm
sure we've all had you know either uh
you know people who are Trump tards or
friends who are like well he's not so
bad and it's like this guy these are
these are the two heads of the parties
and they're poisonous people that nobody
believes nobody trusts um and that's
really what's at at stake here it's
certainly not democracy and
um you know for that reason I think we
are going to see a swing to the
Republicans because they are not the
Democrats first and foremost and this
election is going to be like most of the
elections of the past 20 years now where
it's like whoever isn't in power
needs to be taken out of power uh and
then it takes about two years to realize
that the people that we just voted in
are just as bad they might even be worse
because they have been living in
basements you know scraping paint trips
off of you know seller walls and eating
those in the two years that they're out
of power so uh my sense of the biggest
thing uh at stake for me for Matt Welch
uh is that on the ballot in
um a handful of States uh Arizona
Michigan Minnesota Nevada
um uh Pennsylvania Wisconsin there are
Governors and or secretaries of state so
people who are in position to impact the
accounting of votes who are not just
people who have said hey you know the
2020 election was rigged and whatnot but
they've been campaigning pretty openly
on doing things to make sure that they
don't steal the vote away from Donald
Trump next time around when we talk
about the institutions
of democracy being under threat
um it's not very helpful in my point of
view to be vague about it but the
specific candidates are these people uh
many of them
are in a position uh they have a good
puncher's chance of winning and at least
one of them Carey Lake in Arizona was
boosted by democrats
nice job in the primary because they
thought that she'd be easier to beat
those are the races that I will be
watching soon we have talked a little
bit about it already but let's get more
into it uh what is the one
Maine major party closing arguments that
you find most risable opponents points
if you get uh making Whoopi in your
answer Catherine why don't you start I
will not be getting making Whoopi in my
answer just want to clear that up right
now
you know it's a great sports team for
Macon Georgia
I think I think
um it's what I alluded to before which
is that the the closing argument of
Democrats seems to be if you let
Republicans
take control of one or more houses of
Congress democracy as we know or maybe
one or more state legislatures or
Governors Mansions democracy as we know
it will be over and that is not true
that is untrue Bill Moore says it's true
Catherine Bill Maher is wrong in this
respect because it's you know we have a
great uh cover story from a couple of
issues Ago by Eric Bane which I
recommend to you about how uh our
elections have always been messy and we
are in a messier than usual moment like
I don't mean to say everything is
completely fine
um and there really are some battles
happening for control of kind of
specific semi-obscure bureaucratic
entities that control how election
outcomes get communicated and tallied
that I think are worth paying attention
to but broadly speaking our democracy
will be fine
and certainly this midterm election
is not is not the linchpin of History so
I guess I'm just back to my very very
beginning of my first answer which is
you know is this the most important
election of our lifetimes no it's not
it's an election it's a regular election
and some people are being kind of extra
bonus dickish
um but that is neither here okay but if
you're like democracy 18 months old
this is the only election of your
lifetime
hey boom right like there's at least
four reasons staffers with uh with uh
Offspring who are 18 months old are you
think that was just pandemic really no I
thought you're gonna say they're at
least at least uh four reasons staffers
for whom this is the first election of
their lifetimes we got some some youths
on the staff now certainly Billy Binion
looks like that uh Peter what what is
the major party uh closing argument that
is sticking in your craw whatever across
it's a synthesis of what you talked
about with the Republican
um races where there are Governors Etc
who are promising to install people or
sort of change processes uh in order to
ensure that Donald Trump wins next time
even if he doesn't win I I think is kind
of the argument there
um right so even if he doesn't want Maga
stop the steel movement I think on the
one hand and the flip side of that which
is what Catherine is uh you know
mentioned which is the Democratic
argument that democracy is in Peril and
so I think Republicans are in a real
really disturbing place with when it
comes to the machinations of democracy
and voting and whether or not Trump
actually won in 2020 Trump trump lost
and a lot of Republicans have not
accepted that and they need to and
they've built a movement around the idea
that actually he did and it's just
totally out of touch with reality and I
think it's really poisonous for our
politics at the same time Democrats have
responded with this argument that
therefore democracy is in Peril and you
you what at the the implication of their
argument of the democracy is imperil
arguments is that you then have no
choice but to vote for Democrats and not
just no choice but to vote for Democrats
no choice but to vote for Democrats and
enthusiastically support their entire
stupid policy agenda the one that landed
us within the place we are right now
economically the the one that you know
that we have seen for the last two years
from Demi from Joe Biden a democratic in
the white house and I a unified
Democratic party in Congress and Josh
Barrow who is you know not a Libertarian
not and sort of an interesting Senator
left guy recently wrote a really smart
piece in which he basically argued that
if you're telling voters
that democracy is in Peril to the point
where you don't have a choice but to
vote for Democrats then what you're
telling them is you've already lost the
choice and you've already lost democracy
and it's it's just a terrible argument
from from like a kind of logical
perspective but also from a I think even
from a pro-democracy perspective because
what it says is is that in fact you
don't have a choice you shouldn't have a
choice and you've got to support all of
our dumb spending stuff if you want to
restore democracy you've got to support
all of our bad ideas our entire you know
crappy policy agenda now Republicans are
responding with terrible non-policy
ideas I mean if you look at the
Republican policy agenda to the extent
that it exists it is in many ways just
it's it's half-assed and barely there
and so Republicans are not exactly you
know on the ball about this stuff either
but the way that Democrats have
responded to uh Republican election
nonsense is I think not particularly
helpful and it it has landed us in a
really sort of unpleasant place going
into this midterm election
I would remind everyone that um the same
people who were making the uh democracy
is dying in in Broad sunlight argument
right now uh tended to wildly
mischaracterize the Georgia election Law
changes
um uh not that long ago uh President
Biden called it you know not just Jim
Crow but Jim Eagle
um
at some point and uh and doesn't that
make it more American
wow I hadn't thought about that no it
gives me the Jim Henson Sam Eagle Energy
that's what I think of when I hear that
I'm trying to grow my eyebrows out just
like that uh Nick I I know you broadly
agree with what Peter and Catherine both
just said I would invite you as you uh
expand on that to take into
consideration that you know in 2016 or
2015 you we didn't think Donald Trump
was going to win uh in January early
January of 2021 we didn't think that the
capital was going to get ransacked and
that 140 Republicans would not vote to
certify the election is it possible that
the hysterics hysterical though they may
be are causing us to underrate the
possibilities for chicanery yes I think
so depending on how you define chicanery
there might be more things like the
January 6 riots or something but in
terms of voting I mean you know the
elections have been really solid over
the past you know 20 years like there
aren't any you know everybody has gone
looking for this and unless you're
Dinesh D'Souza whose books keep getting
pulped by Publishers before they can see
print you know like nobody has found
wide scale large-scale voter fraud that
matters in any given election what we're
seeing actually in this to build off of
what uh Catherine and Peter were talking
about is like we're not saying the death
of democracy in the 21st century we are
seeing the growth of it like you know uh
the voting eligible population which is
the number of people who are voting age
who are actually able to vote in the
21st century has been like higher than
it has been in the previous 50 years in
2018 we had record midterm turnout we're
going to see that again or something
like that this is what democracy looks
like and it kind of sucks but it's not
going away I mean like this is this is
exactly I can remember writing for re
season and one of my first I think it
was one of my first editorials as
editor-in-chief of the magazine in 2000
people were bitching and Mining about
the vanishing Vote or people didn't vote
enough people didn't vote enough like
we've had 22 years of people voting in
record percentages in every election
across the board and it sucks so if you
want democracy this is what it looks
like um and it's not good to go to your
you know your earlier appointment about
like secretaries of states and people
like Carrie like who is out of touch
with reality on many many core issues
including whether or not Donald Trump
was elected president in 2020 or not
I'm hopeful uh and this may be like
totally you know just because there's
nothing else to do but hope for the best
but in Boy Scouts uh you know and I was
an eagle scout they you know one of
those things they taught us yeah Joe
Eagle Jim Eagle Scout uh that but one of
the things that the uh the leaders of
the troop sawdust was like when you see
a troublemaker give them some
responsibility and it straightens them
out and how are secretaries of State
like they have to oversee elections that
are going to be closely watched
Etc like it's going to be really hard
for them to be in charge and throw
elections one way or the other
um because there's so much scrutiny and
also the election results need to be
believed in order for them to stand so
I'm less worried about this kind of
broad-based chicanery although I do
think politicians whether they're
right-wing or left-wing and there's some
on both parts who are so blatantly out
of touch with basic reality should be
called in on that all of them feel like
I just understood for the first time how
Matt Welsh became editor-in-chief
yeah well you know I also realized like
after the fact I was like oh that's why
I was made a leader of the church yeah
you know so it's it's just Turtles here
for sure
OMG uh I'm going to take as my entrance
something that uh suiterman alluded to
before which is a large Democratic party
closing argument
um as Joe Biden said about a thousand
times in the last five days Republicans
have embraced a plan
Embrace and plan those are keywords here
to Sunset Social Security Medicare
within five years they're gonna put it
on the chopping block
no
that's not true it's not true it's
important that that's not true he's the
president he's saying the thing it isn't
true there isn't a plan
there is one stupid Rick Scott bullet
point list from February that includes
18 words in which some of it is that all
federal programs should be sunset within
five years
um doesn't say anything about social
security Medicare
um in follow-up questions in March of
this year someone's like oh did you did
you mean Social Security Medicare is
like nope nobody I know wants to do that
so that's the plan that Republicans have
embraced the plan that doesn't exist
um that is not supported by anything
that anyone is campaigning on at all
right now it it hides the reality that
the Republican party of 2022 is
basically unrecognizable when it comes
to things like entitlement reform than
it was in 2010 because Donald Trump won
the argument against Paul Ryan where is
Paul Ryan right now he's crying in his
money that's where Paul Ryan is right
now he doesn't matter at all Donald
Trump does part of the reason why is
because Trump said I am going to protect
your Social Security and Medicare screw
these bean counter Republican
conservatives and now you have the
rising class of Republicans who matter
are saying stuff that like like Masters
did about libertarianism that it doesn't
work it sucks uh and then it gets the
endorsement from the Liberty can I vote
for him now that he is explicitly
anti-libertarian and I'm a Libertarian I
mean I mean a lot of members of the
libertarian party it's very attractive
to the self-hatred of the yeah
I think you got to go move to Arizona
first or uh uh or at least try to uh can
I get a mule some kind of mule that will
take my vote there like a like an actual
mammal or yeah I just know there's 2 000
mules and they're running votes uh there
is hey Peter at least one other quasi
not quite plan that suggests that
Republicans might want to do something
to Medicare and Social Security it is uh
the uh it it is the house Republican
study committees 122 page budget which
includes lines like adjust the Medicare
eligibility age to reflect life
expectancy it's not a plan to Sunset
Medicare and Social Security it sounds
like exactly the same thing as Sun
settings
it's got some tables that show that if
you don't do anything Medicare is one of
the big trust funds well not not be able
to pay all of its bills like if you if
you continue on just not doing anything
and then it says well maybe we should do
something
right
um the uh so what's great about that is
that the um uh those proposals are
basically with one exception
indistinguishable from the proposals
that the uh bipartisan Simpson Bowles
the committee came up with in
2010-11 uh when uh Barack Obama
appointed a uh committee to look at
long-term entitlement reform because
we're not going to kick that down the
road on out of my watch we're gonna
finally like solve this problem this was
I remember that broadly uh understood by
people who pretended at least at
seriousness about long-term fiscal
whatevers um that you had to make at
least those small adjustments the other
the thing that the Republican study
committee thing does that is uh Beyond
where they went is that they wanted to
give younger
um workers the option to opt out of the
social security retirement and invest
things on their own which has been
something that Republican or
conservative White papers have been
advocating
for 50 years and it goes precisely
nowhere ever the closest that we came to
any of this and Nick might remember this
because he has memory cells is the
ownership Society uh like flaccid
attempt by George W bush in his second
term that just sort of collapsed almost
on contact
um it's not I mean it obviously didn't
happen but there I actually think
that maybe I was just like a delusional
youth at that time but I remember
following that conversation and thinking
okay it seems like there is a a
reasonable possibility that we will get
nothing like actual privatization
nothing like you know something that
solves our budget problems but maybe a
little 401K ish account for some people
it could it could happen like it was
like crazy to think that like the posing
plan or whatever was was a a potential
reality in that moment we already uh
have that though you can you can
voluntarily say forever yeah that's true
tax advantage but specifically you know
some of the money out of Social Security
as it's currently constructed and put
into these other accounts now I remember
thinking at the time also those accounts
will get ransacked when uh you know the
next moment that politicians want them
and also they'll be somehow constrained
in ways that are damaging and you know
ultimately don't serve uh taxpayers but
was I crazy to think that might have
happened at that moment so George W bush
did in fact sign into law hsas the
health savings accounts but if I recall
correctly that was at least somewhat
linked to the Medicare reform and
expansion bill that uh that that also
established Medicare Part D so he
expanded Medicare while also building
hsas into the system
right but then there was the Social
Security equivalent of it yeah
it was after he was re-elected and he
you know he won big it was the first
president since his father to win with
the majority of the popular vote mandate
and he said I have a lot of uh you know
capital and I'm going to play it and he
he went after immigration and Social
Security and within six to eight months
both of those you know both of those
plans were just totally gone reason had
an interesting debate about privatizing
social security between Tyler Cowan and
James Glassman people can look it up
it's probably from 2004 to 2005.
um I think subsequent to the Obamacare
uh kind of arguments it'll be
interesting to see Republicans I don't
think can do that if any kind of you
know mandatory any kind of privatization
of retirement spending is based on
involuntary contributions or that you
have to sign up
that won't make sense anymore all right
we're going to get uh we're gonna talk
more midterms uh uh later we're now
going to get to our listener email of
the week here in a moment
but first look we're all responsible
adults here we do what it takes to
ensure our families in case of medical
emergency but what many of us don't
realize is that health insurance won't
always cover the full cost of an
emergency medical flight even
comprehensive coverage can leave you
with high deductibles and co-pays that's
where airmed Care Network comes in when
you see when you sign up to become a
member should any such emergency arise
you will not see a bill for air Medical
Transport when flown by an amcn provider
your med care flying machines transport
more than 100 000 patients each year
best of all this peace of mind for your
whole family can be yours beginning at
the low low price of just 85 a year
listeners to the round table can get
gift cards to their new memberships for
up to fifty dollars through their Visa
or Amazon simply visit
airmedcarenetwork.com reason and use the
offer code reason start protecting your
family do it today you'll be glad you
did all right reminder to send us your
succinct emails to Roundtable at
reason.com this one comes from Dave
Matthew no s who writes in part hello
Roundtable my pithy query is this do you
think candidates would attract the 8 to
15 percent of Independence I presume
this is Matt cutting in that that's the
number that he's attaching to
independence by refreshingly stating
their actions in office will have little
to no effect on individualized happiness
for example Democrats and Republicans
have squabbled over tax cuts a somewhat
nominal
39.6 percent to
37.37 for the top rate while federal
spending on every single mandatory and
discretionary program has remained
relatively unscathed yet the tax cuts
are held up as an US versus them when
discussing policy will cynicism ever
Prevail are there any real-life bulworth
examples now for you 40 somethings on
this podcast bulworth was a late 1990s
Warren Beatty picture in which a and
Holly Barry uh and yes a sleaze bag
Democratic politician organizes his own
assassination I think he's like a
senator and then ours uh goes in a
bender uh because he's unhappy and he
smokes a lot of pot and gets super drunk
and then uh shows up in public and
starts rapping really badly about the
reality of politics and improbably
um I think he might was there a
blackface uh I'm not sure there's actual
Black Faces but he did wear a skull a
skull cap he improbably starts betting
Halle Berry which is exciting for Warren
Beatty uh and uh oh and for her because
he was Warren Beatty back then he wasn't
the desiccated corpse who misread the uh
winning picture a couple years got the
Academy I heard betting just in like
b-e-t-t instead of betting and I was
like was there a poker game in which
Halle Berry was wagered in this film
like I essentially but anyways he
started rapping the truth about how
Democratic politicians are full of crap
and he probably started getting super
popular
um and so people thought hey maybe
that's if they would just tell us
honestly so Catherine
could the fantasy of having a politician
uh suddenly uh become popular by telling
the cynical truth about the limitation
of politics and the cynicism of it
um uh and then suddenly succeeding could
that ever come true
I think that happens regularly I think
almost every time that we elect a
celebrity
um to office that's essentially what's
happening including perhaps the election
of Donald Trump I think many people who
voted for him perceived him to be that
guy they perceived him to be someone who
was just like you know what I am not
beholden to the ritual of this thing and
I'm just gonna say what I want to say I
think the the delusion that at least
those of us of a Libertarian persuasion
have is that
that character is somehow correlated in
the end to doing anything even remotely
good in office and I think those things
are unrelated uh and that is what I have
taken away at least from not just Donald
Trump but actually the kind of populist
uh the reactionary populism that's kind
of cropped up around the world in the
last four or five years
um people who seem like they are doing
this it seem like they are being
bulworth I guess on this day like Ferris
Bueller's political day off is what it
sounds like you just described you know
those people are subject to all of the
same human vices as regular stuff shirt
politicians and perhaps even more Peter
this is an open invitation for you to
assess your own favorite or at least
favorite cinematic presidencies and or
to rebut Catherine's assertion that uh
Trump equals bullworth or both equals
Trump so I think the thing that people
forget about bulworth is that the most
memorable rap couplets were actually
about I hate this about health policy yo
oh no yo everybody gonna get sick
someday but nobody knows how they're
gonna pay Healthcare Managed Care hmos
ain't gonna work no sir not those
because the thing that's the same in
every one of these is these mother
effers there the insurance companies and
then two characters named Cheryl and
Tanya chant insurance insurance and he
says yeah yeah you can call it
single-payer or Canadian way only
socialized medicine will ever save the
day come on now let me hear that dirty
word socialism
oh socialism and honest and what you
have to remember is what you have to
remember I love it what you have to
remember is this movie came out in the
late 1990s and that was not a reaction
to Republicans trying to privatize
whatever that was a reaction to Hillary
care and to the mainstream Democratic
party's attempt to reform the Health
Care System it's also uh worth pointing
out that Warren Beatty you know cut his
political teeth in the 1972 campaign of
George McGovern where he helped a war
hero lose virtually every state in the
country but I think you can draw a
pretty direct line from bulworth and its
sort of um from from that style of
politics to Bernie Sanders and to the
kind of progressive takeover or at least
the rising Progressive Movement that we
have seen Post Obama in the Democratic
party where they're like well if we just
say that all these mainstream things you
know uh that that like we we've tried
before if we just say that's you know
that's [ __ ] right if we just call it
out then somehow or another we'll win
and it's it's a little I mean it's
related to what I was saying earlier
about inflation like they're the
Democratic party has decided that you
can win all of these things just through
a kind of blunt you know sort of we're
just gonna say the truth man messaging
that I don't know if it exactly derives
from bulworth it's not like bulworth had
uh you know was the first popular
incarnation of that idea we've we've
seen it for decades at the same time
bulworth was a was popular in certain
circles uh developed a cult reputation
and bulworth uh it bullworth plays at
least some small role in putting us in
the you know sort of
um in an America where Bernie Sanders
isn't President but play but is
surprisingly influential within the
Democratic Party
so bullworth is Trump although he really
isn't I mean I think this is it's it's
interesting I I Peter I think that's a
really fascinating read and it's really
helpful to remember you know bullworth's
main thing was about health care in
response to Hillary care but ultimately
when you look at people like Bernie
Sanders or AOC they are not particularly
influential uh and you know one thing
that's interesting is when Nancy Pelosi
vacates uh which is going to be probably
sooner rather than later because of that
[ __ ] up attack on her husband and when
Biden you know when they stop giving the
electric you know the starter jumps jump
starts every morning so it seems as if
he's still alive
um what comes next will be interesting
but people the hardcore socialism
progressives in the Democratic party
like AOC and her uh you know her uh girl
gang like don't have any institutional
power or any electoral Powers so
um that's kind of comforting uh was um I
was going to point people to matches in
response to the reader's question
um you know the the real life example
and I think Catherine might have been uh
getting to this was Arnold
Schwarzenegger in California when he
became Governor he was a true Outsider
who came in very idealistically Matt
Welch uh you and I wrote positively of
the potential for him to be a true
change agent in in American politics
because he was an old-time I'm socially
liberal I'm fiscally conservative and he
was a truth teller and was it three
months six months within his election he
was finished yeah yeah I mean it was so
bad but then the other guys like
somebody like zelenski you know in
Ukraine got elected and is actually kind
of rising to the challenge he's kind of
a bulworth type character wow and it's a
bull worth equals Trump
he played the piano with his penis in a
an accomplishment that is true before he
became president that's pretty good it
is actually that's better than Warren
Beatty rapping although in some way it
may be for anyone who does does not
understand the sort of the popular
culture or sort of uh role that
Schwarzenegger was cast in when he was
governor you should go back and read the
Esquire profile of him by Tom Tom junod
uh from 2009 Arnold Schwarzenegger is
president of 12 of us that is just this
incredibly sort of laudatory like
Schwarzenegger is going to come in there
and beat up all the bad guys and just do
the and like be the action hero that
California needs in the governor's
office piece it's it's kind of a
fascinating piece of Journalism a great
read I think it didn't hold up very well
as a as a piece of political prediction
but it will give you a sense of how he
was seen and how he was portrayed in the
Press yeah instead of the Terminator we
uh Schwarzenegger we got jingle all the
way I want to confess uh having attended
the uh the very brief moment in which
Warren Beatty was a possible
presidential candidate in 1999 we have
memory hold this but he was given a
Eleanor Roosevelt award at the Beverly
Hilton in October of 1999 and people
like is he gonna run is bullworth gonna
run for president and this place was
Phil it was probably the most like
glittering uh event I've ever gone to
all these Hollywood people Stanley
shinebaum there the ancient ACLU
benefactor uh Norman Lear was there a
bunch of people Bob Shearer and they're
really they're hanging on every word as
he can run is he gonna run and he gave
he gave a really really boring speech
that was kind of like uh by the Numbers
Bernie but without the Charisma
um and it was sort of like he thought he
was being ultramanic and not but yeah
people were writing credulous articles
in October of 1999 so that shows you how
the political campaign cycle has that
was Y2K man we were you know [ __ ] out
of our minds we're out of our minds
history you know we were wearing uh
planes dropping from it was over and
bullworth was going to be president this
sounds perfectly reasonable to me
you know a great truth-telling movie
worth watching which is better than
bulworth's 1972's the candidate with
Robert Redford which is based on the uh
improbable run and victory of John
Tunney the son of a heavyweight champion
Gene Tunney against George Murphy who
had been a a Hollywood movie star uh you
know who's friends with Ronald Reagan it
was governor at the time but
um it's about a young idealistic
candidate who runs and wins by telling
the truth and that it has a great early
70s ending where the political
consultant who has helped massage you
know make the message live
Etc you know Robert Redford turns to me
he's like oh we're elected what do we do
and he's like I don't know that's like
your job like I'm just here for the
messaging and we've had you know a
series of people Reagan is the great
exception of like a celebrity who you
know first became Governor which is no
small thing in govern for two terms you
know effectively you could like him or
this like him but he got his stuff done
or a lot of stuff done and then the
president but that's virtually never
happened all right let's go to a
lightning round about the midterms
everyone round the table gets to tell us
a single race ballot initiative whatever
thing that is happening on Tuesday that
you find of particular perhaps
idiosyncratic interest for whatever
reason Catherine money starts yeah I'm
keeping an eye on California prop 31
where we're going to uh you know protect
the children
from The Vaping
um this is something that reason of
course has covered quite a lot and
um it's a real classic example of a
failure to think about trade-offs
um you know the the numbers are already
trending in a more positive direction
even if you are worried about the teens
and their Vapes um that those numbers
seem to be going down and of course
teens vaping or anyone vaping is still
far far better than anyone smoking a
cigarette even though cigarettes are
awesome and amazing and they are the
best drug and the best drug delivery
device ever invented by Humanity they
kill you they do kill you and so
um we should be making uh alternatives
to them widely available even perhaps to
the children I mean Vapes for the
children is what I'm saying here and um
that's a sign that your children are not
as old as much by the way this is easy
for me to say with a with an 11 year old
but
um the one reason that I've been paying
attention to prop 31 is because it is
such a class example of this like
misleading titling and description of
ballot initiatives which like California
specializes in but all states do this
where even if you are an informed voter
even if you have a highly developed
opinion on the policy area when you look
at the language of the ballot initiative
itself you're like I don't know what's
going on here I literally don't know
which way to vote to get the outcome I
want this is I think like an under an
underappreciated problem with taking
these questions directly to the people
is that the people are voting on some
confusing and badly written sentences I
think prop 31 will probably pass and
that will be uh Nick what is something
that you're paying attention to uh so
I'm uh following the uh Georgia Senate
race between Herschel Walker who is one
of these people who I mean his reality
testing I don't think he would be let
out of most insane asylums in America uh
and he's against Raphael Warnock who is
a terrible seems to be kind of a
terrible human being if you look into
his past but is also a terrible
politician who's voted for every big
government thing that Joe Biden has
asked you know plus some uh but Chase
Oliver the libertarian uh candidate in
that race is polling between one to five
percent probably going to cover the
spread between these two Knuckleheads
and uh Chase Oliver is a really classic
pre-mises caucus LP guy who you know
walks the socially liberal fiscally
conservative line which we can get into
philosophical debates about whether
that's good or bad but political in
retail politics that's pretty good and
Georgia is an interesting State because
it's flipping back and forth between
people but but it's not purple it really
is like there's a lot of red people and
a lot of blue people there so I'm
curious to see how Oliver does and in
particular when you compare him to the
Arizona race where uh uh you know uh
Blake Masters versus Mark Kelly where
the libertarian Mark Victor who had been
pulling his high you know in double
digits in some races caved and said okay
you know all Libertarians for Blake
Masters because I talked to him for a
while and he claimed to have carried
Human Action around in his backpack when
he was in grammar school or something
like that so I see the Georgia race not
only interesting because of this red
blue you know kind of Showdown but also
about how is the lp going to go uh how
is it how is it going to go going
forward because you know they're Under
New Management Oliver has been critical
of the mises caucus but is going to have
one of the very best and most impactful
if we're using that word uh outcomes I
think in in this election cycle so I'm
very interested in Georgia fascinating
for a lot of reasons not just because
it's the site of the alleged Jim Eagle
election law but we might see a lot of
tickets splitting right Brian Kemp might
might win Governor over Stacy Abrams
who's a one definitely is kind of went I
mean he's like up almost you know double
digits the five most pause and yet
Warnock might win it's just it's uh it's
it's fascinating and it'll put a lot of
uh narratives to the test and kind of
scramble them in ways
um that if it happens that way would be
kind of like a hopeful uh for to me uh
outcome Peter what is something you've
been looking at in some ways it's
something that I haven't been looking at
unfortunately it's another Georgia race
this one is the um the Marjorie Taylor
greens District uh Republican
representative she will not be there
there will not be a Libertarian on the
ballot in that race because the
libertarian didn't make the ballot
because of George's insane
um ballot access rules which were
designed initially to keep Communists
off the ballot but now have uh turned
into basically a sort of a way for the
two parties to ensure that there is no
third party competition now and there
was a there was an interesting potential
candidate who tried to get onto the
ballot Angela Pence she describes
herself Catherine will love this as an
anarchist at heart she is someone who
thinks that America needs more
immigration a smaller government's less
control over individual decisions and
she says that she was activated in her
sort of political Journey because she
felt like the Republicans were turning
toward authoritarianism but she couldn't
bring herself you know to pick to choose
either Donald Trump or Hillary Clinton
in 2016. hey hey that sounds kind of
familiar this seems like somebody who
would be a good person to have on the
ballot she wasn't going to win Angela
Pence was not going to beat Mercury
Taylor green but it would have given
people a choice in that district and I
think it would have been a better race
had she been in it um she did however
tweet about a week ago that she has been
humbled by the number of people
messaging to say that they wrote her in
for the for George's 14th congressional
district so people do still have a
little bit of a choice but it's harder
because she's not on the ballot and I
think it's a shame Eric Bane covered
this for us over the summer
if you want to if if you want to read
about George's uh ballot access laws um
and how that system was developed and
how it is being used now uh his article
how George's landish ballot access law
is protecting Marjorie Taylor green and
the two-party system is at reason.com
the speaking of uh ballot access the one
that I'm paying closest attention to
probably uh election on Tuesday is the
New York gubernatorial race which has
only two people on the ballot
unfortunately uh New York also has
terrible laws governing third parties uh
libertarian Larry sharp was unable to
get on the ballot it was challenged
um the law of underlying law was rough
and then uh his actual uh Signature
Collection uh was challenged by Lee
zeldon uh the Republican running uh so
there's only two people on the ballot uh
and the last like 36 48 Hours of
pre-election coverage has been such an
absolute freak out meltdown uh mostly by
democrats and left leaners at the
possibility that Zelda might be
competitive in this race um you can see
Kathy hokel's uh closing commercials on
television are all about how she's going
to fight crime the hardest so that's a
different message than she had a month
ago there's going to be a lot of
national discussion there's people
blaming Eric Adams the mayor of New York
already because he's leaning into cons
false conservative narratives about
Rising crime and such like it'll be an
it'll be an interesting
um it'll have more National implications
than most and then it's you know it's my
Governor so um I have personal uh skin
in the game as well uh and it's a it's a
damn toot and shame that there isn't a
uh a sensible libertarian on that ballot
uh would have been easier and I just
want to say that Nick I know that you
wrote in uh candidate there I believe I
wrote on you uh I you know if elected I
will not serve but if I have to
um uh you will be jailed um just uh
preemptively
um I'm already I've I'm taking a tunnel
to New Jersey
in your mind all right if uh you know by
uh like 11 P.M tomorrow night I'll be
gone the boring machine is there yeah
hyperloop yeah is it a slow boring or is
it a fast board all right let's let's
get to our end of podcast what we have
been consuming Nick why don't you lead
us off
okay so uh speaking of Marjorie Taylor
green who is another person who is
delusional I mean these are you know
there was a famous in the early 70s
there was a famous psychiatric paper uh
on being sane in insane places
um where a it where a psychologist uh
had a bunch of grad students go to
mental institutions and give vague
descriptions of something and then saw
how many people were seen as insane
Marjorie Taylor green is insane I think
if she was put if if a battery of
doctors asked her basic questions they
would be like this person probably
should not be operating heavy machinery
or driving a car or wielding you're on
the side of the liberal medical
establishments I am you know what lock
her up lock her up along with Violet
the Goldwater roll here
uh yeah you know well thankfully I'm not
a uh psychologist so I'm not bound by
those rules but um and uh Barry
Goldwater in 1964 you know there were
reasons to worry in any case so uh um
the reason I'm talking about Marjorie
Taylor green is that I'm reading Robert
Draper's uh new book Weapons of Mass
delusion when the Republican Party lost
its mind uh Draper is a really excellent
journalist who hails from Texas uh he
wrote flatteringly of Matt and me in the
uh the you know with is increasingly
looking like the high water mark Matt or
at least of our term the libertarian
moment in 2014. uh yeah I guess it is
true that when something appears in the
New York Times it means it's over uh but
Draper had written the cover story about
Rand Paul and Libertarians called has
the libertarian moment finally arrived
uh and we're still waiting on the answer
I think but uh but we know it didn't
arrive at any time since 2014 but this
book is a you know from a guy who is
sympathetic to kind of uh mainstream
Republican conservativism he opens with
a he's a great writer and he opens with
a uh remembrance of his father who was a
Conservative Republican in Texas at a
time when it was not easy to be a
republican in Texas
um just kind of being dismayed as he was
dying to see what the Republican Party
had become over the past five or six
years
um and it's uh it's highly worth reading
because the trumpification of the
Republican party has you know destroyed
that party in terms of principles uh
even when you look at people like Rand
Paul or Thomas Massey uh you know people
like uh Justin Amash of course have been
chased out but they're you know
Republicans do not stand for anything
remotely libertarian anymore I think and
that is disturbing as hell
um and they are mostly obsessed with
attacking leftism and all kinds of stuff
wherever they see it to the distraction
of being in favor of things like
immigration free markets Free Speech uh
you name it um I highly recommend
Weapons of Mass delusion when the
Republican Party lost its mind
um and this is not to say okay this all
the trouble in the world is because of
Republicans the Democrats have their own
problems and they are going to be
dealing with that in a big way come you
know whenever these election results are
certified
um but the Republican party because it's
going to win big in the midterms is
going to go on as if like look at us
we're winning we're winning you know
let's keep doing what we're doing and
what they're doing is terrible and often
insane Catherine what have you been
consuming I have been continuing to work
my way through suggestions from uh
podcast listeners in my convalescence
but the one I want to recommend is
um Susanna Clerk's novel pyreneesie you
might remember her name she wrote
Jonathan strange and Mr Norrell but this
novel is almost entirely unrelated to to
that book it's
actually quite hard to describe but it
is kind of a
fever dreamish other world in which we
meet a character who doesn't seem to
have contact with the world as we know
it but
um maybe once did it's sort of starts
out as a like almost Umberto Echo type
allegory story and ends up as a dark
Academia Thriller and
um I really enjoyed it I found it to be
like very very absorbing and right after
I finished it I watched the Netflix
series I started watching the Netflix
series based on Michael pollan's book
how to change your mind which follows a
very similar path
um so basically
you know
say you had some experiences with
psychedelics and you were in Academia
how did that go for you in the 20th
century like that Arc very much follows
the Arc of this book so much so that I
almost wonder if she had it in mind as
she was writing so if you are kind of
interested in
a really really big world-changing Ideas
have no place in the industry of ideas
that is Academia
um I I would recommend actually both the
Netflix series uh and this book
um and also if you want to just kind of
not be where you are
um this book is extremely transporting
and if you are me with a broken kneecap
um that was much needed so pyreneesi by
Susanna Clarke
Peter I watched the movie tar
um the new film by Todd field starring
Kate Blanchett as a superstar classical
music conductor the reason angle is that
this is about cancel culture or me too
and it's been called a kind of a
broadside against cancel culture I think
the movie is actually much more complex
much more tricky than that and it's
really kind of a Rorschach test because
once you if you sort of get away from it
for a little while you realize that all
the things you sort of think happened
that the movie is suggesting that the
the classical music conductor here is
getting canceled for that you think like
oh yeah she probably she probably did
that you realize it never shows you any
of it and so it's an interesting
exercise just in kind of
non-judgmentalism and the ways that uh
you know that we can perceive things
that are happening just because of how
we see a character and a person Kate
Blanchett is kind of incredible and I
think this movie is actually much more
about self-creation and self-mythology
and whether individual genius exists uh
but importantly for me it's also about
music and the power of the power of
beauty and great art and the way that
great art just kind of justifies itself
and what what it demands from us and
what it can get away with
uh my pick uh I would usually do a
caveat throat clear about how the world
doesn't need anything new having to do
with the Beatles
um and I realize that's just not true uh
because the uh the generation of the
successor generation to The Fab Four
um people like Sean Lennon people like
Danny Harrison and Giles Martin the son
of uh George Martin their legendary
producer they keep cranking out really
interesting new product that allows one
to enjoy a really good band much much
more in this particular case 10 days ago
they released a new uh stereo mix of
revolver their classic 1966 album It's
revolver Super Deluxe or something like
that let me look at the exact name the
revolver special edition but people are
calling it Super Deluxe on the interwebs
um it the Beatles uh when they made
their uh and a lot of bands back in the
day the dawn of stereo they would work
all uh on their mono mixes forever and
then the stereo mix would be kind of
done at the last minute if those of us
who had crappy speakers all their lives
you could always tell when you're
listening to a Beatles album because one
thing was always panned way left and
then you wouldn't get the harmony
because the your right speaker was
messed up
um so this thing I listened to and I'm
not an audiophile like suiterman is
um I don't have big speakers don't care
about that stuff
um it is just so different and big and
full and you can't really describe why
it's not like oh there's an element I
never heard before it just the whole
thing a great classic album when the
Beatles had stopped touring and were now
working as the studio was an instrument
um classic tracks like Tomorrow Never
Knows tax man
um uh it is it's remarkable like I
noticed it in my chest on the first list
and again I'm not the person who who
normally reacts that way and then
there's a bunch of great uh you know
outtakes and different versions you
could see that the Beatles were
basically trying to respond to the birds
favorite band
and and trying to exceed them at the
same time uh jangly guitars and
harmonies and these kind of things and
you can see them work it out in real
time but the actual just remix of
revolver is so great it's so much better
than what was already really really
great
um and it should put to rest finally for
anyone who actually cares about the
drums as an instrument don't don't ever
don't ever talk smack about Ringo Starr
that's one of the best drumming records
you will ever hear in your life it's
fantastic
um Nick you the drums on Tomorrow Never
Knows are awesome yeah and it's not just
it's it's so bizarre and wonderful and
perfect yeah and uh oh and like one of
the outtakes
um there wasn't on the album originally
but they recorded some singles Paperback
Writer and Rain especially uh rain
um has over the years you know it's
legendary as being a one of the greatest
bass lines you've ever heard and the
drumming is really great too turns out
you find out
um that version that we've been hearing
forever is slowed down the reversion
that they recorded with a really
complicated fancy crazy bass line and
really good drums was about I don't know
one-third faster so go listen to that
it'll blow your freaking mind that the
level of musicianship on these guys at
that moment in their lives it's
fantastic Giles Martin's been been
working through the catalog kind of
backwards from let it be down here using
demixing technology that Peter Jackson
is doing so he's sort of like on The
Cutting Edge of what you can do uh with
uh with stereo remix and stuff and it's
just you know every year it seems like
they're producing something last year it
was the the incredible uh documentary
and this year it's the revolver thing
and hats off to to exploiting the asset
and yet making it uh kind of more
interesting for uh deep fans it's really
great at camera can I also uh make a
pitch match speaking of The Beatles or
the Beatles second or SEC 2.5 generation
Sean Ono Lennon's Twitter feed is
absolutely one of the best things online
right now and I hope he doesn't go to
Mastodon where we will you know he'll
never be seen again even as everybody is
going there right but uh he's he's a
great musician really interesting
collaborator all over the place but his
kind of musings on politics and culture
I wouldn't say they're libertarian per
se but they are not traditionally
left-wing or conventionally right-wing
and he's just great and he's in the in
the middle of a big Twitter stream fight
Feud right now so go check out Sean I
don't know what else as a big speakers
guy I will just second that it sounds
fantastic it on big speakers oh yeah oh
yeah it's right it's it's bigger it's
crunchier right like it sounds it sounds
both more modern and more more of itself
right it's sort of like like the the ins
like you can it's almost when you listen
to it on on great speakers it sounds
like maybe you're not quite in the room
with them playing in it but it's like
you're in the the the studio looking
through the glass listening through the
the monitors right like it has that sort
of directness of sound and the clarity
of it um in a way that I like revolver
is my favorite Beatles album and um I've
probably uh I've probably listened to it
half a dozen times already
nice it'll also uh remind you that the
uh obviously the uh Liam Noel Gallagher
listened to that album five trillion
times like every single mannerism of
every single song is contained in
revolver in the Oasis output all right
Catherine wake up what hi good morning
just to feel something yeah
um so uh thanks for listening
um uh tune in next Monday at the same
bat time uh for more stuff I'll be gone
um and uh listen dollar pack pad costs
at uh reason.com podcasts uh Nick do you
have any uh speaking easy uh to talk oh
yeah it's about well we have a fantastic
uh podcast coming up on Wednesday with
Maj Torre uh that is an interview that
was conducted by Zach weismuller uh and
then the reason Speak Easy for people in
New York the next one is uh December 1st
and it features Caitlin Bailey a sex
worker right uh active activist who runs
a group called Old Pros has a great
podcast called Old Pros and also does a
one-woman show called horse eye view so
that uh go to reason.com
events and you can buy tickets for that
on Thursday December 1st and if you like
what we do please go to reason.com
donate in a couple of weeks we'll start
previewing our upcoming web font and
soliciting questions not quite yet but
just going to wet your whistle right
there thanks for listening again and see
you later
[Music]